bienvenue dans cette toute première
vidéo à 360 de zecs comme je le disais
effectivement dans la vidéo que j'ai
fait hier j'ai acheté la sams ou musique
360 qui est la toute nouvelle caméra à
360 degrés de samsung excuse moi j'ai
bouffé un chat aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
ce qui se passe
la version 2010 est cette caméra est
cette caméra est génial parce qu'il
permet effectivement faire des vidéos à
360° donc là on est dans mon petit
studio et on va faire un petit tour
je vais te montrer un petit peu commencé
que chute tu peux déjà soit un
smartphone et auquel cas tu peux
regarder en déplaçant comme ça et tu
seras en 360 et tu pourras le visionner
directement soit tu as des lunettes
samsung qui vont avec dont elle est fan
du est ce si sûr la suite et l'attaqué à
connecter servir comme ça va péter avec
moi dans la pièce dont tu as l'air un
peu plus combles et elle seule la
personne le voir marquer je ne vois pas
là par contre celui recours soit tu es
sur un ordinateur et où quelqu'un tu vas
pouvoir naviguer avec ta souris donc la
toute première chose que je te dise est
effectivement passée caméra elle est
super parce qu'elle permet de faire
plein de choses et notamment avec dans
une pièce le voir un peu ce qui se passe
je suis je suis le côté et c'est un
grand nombre tu te voir du plafond ce
qui a en somme il ya pas grand chose
dans un espèce de plastoc bruit le sol
est dégueulasse annoncé qu'on leur fasse
mais éclairage que j'utilise
habituellement tel que l'a beaucoup je
ne vais pas simplement ma pâte à modeler
parce que sinon on n'aurait pas les yeux
j'en ai
tu peux le bras alors il ya encore un
peu de boulot dans cette salle là je
vais mettre en miroir la profondeur j'ai
mis du rouge là bas au jour ça tu as pu
voir dans la vidéo d'il ya deux jours
voilà donc ça c'est mon lieu de travail
c'est mon petit studio dans lequel fait
des vidéos dans lequel ce mec-là table
pour parler directement de cette fameuse
caméra prendre 60 et samsung
elle a plein plein plein d'intérêt et le
sucre à montrer parce que là tu vois pas
je vais vous mettre votre photo
directement sur mon ipad pour que tu
puisses la voix alors bien sûr le taux
de saïdi ne marche pas tout de suite je
sais pas pourquoi c'est pour emmerder je
pense alors tiens je les friches et de
l'autre côté
et voilà ça c'est l'appareil photo la
voix la petite caméra
donc là on est en train de se filmer
comme ça je lui ai posé sur un pied mais
tu vois que c'est une caméra que tu peux
tenir au point qui est fait pour ça
d'ailleurs si tu veux te balader avec
noah regardes tu vois up
elle est juste top cette petite caméra
qui est vraiment hyper hyper pratique
elle te permet de faire plein de choses
il ya plein de modes différents dedans
pour filmer pour plein de choses tu peux
faire du photo panoramic peut faire des
photos à 360 tu peux faire de la vidéo
directement à 160 et surtout ce qui est
génial avec cette nouvelle caméra c'est
que tu peux faire du 4k en direct
directement sur facebook et sur youtube
donc on fera comme ça ensemble lors
peut-être pas en quatre cafés tanfous
l'aviez pas ce que j'ai pu voir que via
laquelle j'ai ça supporte pas été
terriblement mais on va je pense faire
cavalier seul
lien la one to switch site a suivi on a
eu un petit bug quand j'ai voulu faire
l'autre jour le live via mon adsl ans
c'était pas terrible donc là je pense
qu'on va faire comme ça en fera un test
un pays ça marchera entre nos trois une
solution au fond d'un petit peu on ce
qu'on peut dire sur cette caméra alors
je veux l'utiliser davantage dans les
jours à venir je fais d'autres vidéos en
360 je vous ai aujourd'hui temps mené
avec moi en extérieur voire des des
panoramas des choses super sympa mais il
fait un temps de chien t-il 2 c'est
vraiment dégueulasse
donc pour aujourd'hui on va pas faire ça
par contre on va faire notre truc
je vais t'emmener ce soir on voit le
dernier match de top 14
directement au stade ce soir donc on va
se marrer on va pouvoir regarder un
petit peu ben du coup ce qu'ils disent
pas le petit côté de la buvette est à
sept points du roi voir un peu le match
folle ambiance baladi beau milieu de son
milieu du monde donc on verra un petit
peu comment ça fonctionne et puis
surtout ce qui va être super intéressant
ça fait effectivement de nous permettre
de pouvoir
je dirais se rend compte de la
luminosité parce que ça va être le soir
donc j'y vais à partir de 20 heures
ils feront quand jours normalement bien
que le temps soit pas terrible ça serait
un peu sombre mais surtout on va pouvoir
boire dès que la lumière va laisser en
faible luminosité comment la caméra
comment et cette caméra est ce qu'elles
ajoutent du grain est ce que la qualité
est super comment il micro est ce qu'ils
savent que ça dure pense avoir toutes
ces choses là qui vont être sympa pour
moi là tout de suite je tourne il est 14
heures regarde là tout de suite il est
top
si tu veux bien 14h19 le match j'y vais
ce soir à 20 heures donc pour toi ça va
durer le temps d'un claquement de doigts
heureusement d'ailleurs
pour moi c'est dans quelques heures donc
c'est un essai temps de peaufiner mon
l'utilisation de caméras et de me
préparer davantage donc je fais un
décompte est à 3 ans ni des trois deux
un
du fait de vidéo et 360 voilà donc on va
boire de la bière si on nous sert
tout est vu en réalité tu vois sensible
au charme
la grosse ambiance
le
mais quand même
[Musique]
non
m
esteban
attablé au bar
aulas
à
m
mais pas celle là
ils attaqueront
à
la fibre
cette pratique sous
[Musique]
à
arrêt
les au sol
sébastien
non
fiction
à laisser la monnaie
j'ai avec toi voir hubert ses meilleures
ici
parmi eux
c'est un maquis de rire là quand même
c'est cool c'est que là tu peux regarder
à la volière serait avant les vacances
merci
allez
pour emmanuel
ciao
ça nulle part
dans ce rôle
non
l'écran dispose
si on voit bien mais si on regarde de
l'autre côté il ya les frais des
sponsors quand se monte et c'est les
interviews c'est canal+ la saga lancée
aujourd'hui outre canal+ en prendre une
interview
c
lassé
mais la saison
et qui sait les courses
le maintien
en coulisses un français
que les histoires à ses traits
vous voulez
celle qui le ronge
le tapis
au loin